hi this is luca from lucoclamparelo.com
and i have a very nice surprise
for you guys today i'm going to be
speaking with mariana from spring
spanish
we're going to have a very interesting
discussion in english and spanish
about a wide range of hopefully for you
guys
interesting topics seen from the
perspective of a polyglot
me and her a linguist
in fact she's a fantastic spanish
teacher and linguist
from the spring spanish youtube channel
where you can learn spanish through
interactive and engaging videos
and these guys publish five weekly
spanish lessons
every week they propose a really
interesting learning technique called
chunking you might want to check it out
and subscribe and while you're at it
check out part two of this collaboration
video where you can hear me give tips
about learning languages
in english and in spanish
so without further ado let's get started
with part one
what's the best way to learn words and
chunks
there are countless ways to learn
vocabulary in a foreign language but
the most important thing you have to
keep in mind is to stick to
two key principles the first one is
learn words
in context use words in context so for
example
it's very important to read a lot and
listen a lot
because in stories and in dialogues you
can find how
words fit in context and the second
important thing is that you have to
review words
in one way or another and you better do
it
in a fun way so if you find yourself
scribbling
countless lists of words in isolation
and you find yourself desperate because
you can't commit
them to long-term memory and on top of
that
it's boring then think again and find a
way to make it a rewarding
are countless ways but you have to find
a way that works for you
totally never learn words in isolation
the best way to do it is by learning
them in context so
reading or listening best ways to listen
to a lot of
conversations or dialogues between
native speakers because that's when
you'll go and say like oh
so that's how you say it in english or
spanish or german or whatever language
it is you're learning
the most important thing is that you
learn them in context
and one way to do that is by using
flashcard apps and that's how we do it
at spring spanish actually so
um doing it regularly and like luca says
doing it in
in a way that's fun for you is going
it's the best combination for you to
learn
language in a very natural and easy
way how to get started
historian
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
how to find motivation and stay
consistent
in italian we say la petito via
mangiando that means appetite comes from
eating and i think
that is particularly true when it comes
to learning a language i think we have
the concept of motivation backward for a
number of reasons the first thing
if you are really motivated to learn a
language you must
have your internal lives not just some
random guy said that spanish is cool
and you started to learn spanish you
have to know exactly why maybe you've
gone to the country maybe you've met a
person
knowing exactly why you want to learn a
language makes a huge difference but the
second thing is that
yes you can start learning a language
and it all seems
great but the problem is reality hits
and sometimes we don't feel like doing
stuff during the day for example some
someday we will be tired and we'll have
a lot of things to do in our lives
that's the moment
when it's really important to design a
system
where you reward yourself every time
that you learn spanish so every time you
hit the books you know
even before you do that you want to
learn
and that happens when you're doing stuff
that is interesting
and think about it for a second what
normally happens is that we don't like
you know back in the day we did not like
or maybe we don't like
if you're going to school right now
learning languages at school because
they imposed things upon us and that was
a little bit boring or
it also comes to reading stuff
we used to read and learn languages and
do things we did not
want to do but if you find stuff that is
interesting
that is comprehensible that stimulates
you that rewards you that drives you
that compels you
then things are going to be different
you're going to wake up in the morning
wanting to learn so make sure that you
design a system
where you get a reward you get enjoyment
you are going to learn and like every
moment
of the process because that is how
you're going to feel motivated for a
long run
and trust me you have to be motivated
for a long run because language learning
is not a sprint
it's a marathon on top of what lucas
says
make sure that the language learning is
as useful as it can be in your everyday
life so you can either be planning
a trip to a spanish-speaking country
like mexico for instance or you can have
friends who speak the language
the point is that you make sure that the
language is
used in in a way somehow in your daily
activities
you have to make it necessary in a way
um so you can either just stick to you
know taking a lesson
um every day or listening to something
um like lucas says something fun or
reading something short for 10 minutes
the point is that you make it necessary
and you
stick to that every single day
where to find people to practice with
donde in contrary
practice
for example in google
[Music]
how to get to a really high level
espanol tienes que pasa
tiempo con el espanol
periodicals
funny situations in spanish situations
gracious
he
so there you have it i truly hope you
enjoyed our little chat
don't forget to check her youtube
channel and the second part
of my discussion with mariana you will
find the link to the video
in the description box happy language
learning
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you